Littlefinger, like most characters in the
later seasons, was utterly demolished by David
and Dan’s incompetent writing.
So for this video, I want to try my best to
fix his character and to give him a much better
resolution.
Instead of the abysmal train wreck of an ending
he got in season 7.
The first thing we need to do is assess what
made Littlefinger so great to begin with,
so we can better understand why he was lacking
in the later seasons.
And to me, by far Littlefingers best aspect
is that he plays into one of the show’s
strengths which is the rich mystery of conspiracy.
Littlefinger’s deceptive usage of scheming
and backstabbing is so alluring because he
entangles characters in a thick mud of conflict
that drowns them.
To me, it’s more intriguing than something
like dueling because there’s an air of unpredictability
as to what Littlefinger will do.
We understand his motives, but the actions
he takes to fulfill them is always captivating
to watch unravel.
This is exemplified the most in season 1 where
Littlefinger quite literally kickstarts the
entire conflict of the series.
Without Littlefinger there really wouldn’t
be a show because think about it.
Littlefinger simultaneously manipulates Lysa
Arryn to poison her husband Jon Arryn, which
in turn brings the Starks into the fold, and
he hires an assassin to kill Bran under the
guise that it was the Lannisters who did it.
Littlefinger flat out orchestrates an entire
war in the realm so that he can profit by
helping each side.
I feel like by that alone Littlefinger is
the most evil character in the entire show
and most people normally point to Ramsay or
Joffrey.
The sheer impact that this character has is
arguably the biggest right behind Dany’s
mad queen arc and the Night King.
You can argue that other villains like Tywin
and Joffrey are more deadly, but they were
spurred into doing heinous actions because
of Littlefinger.
Like the red wedding and Tywin destroying
the riverlands wouldn’t be a thing without
Petyr.
What they did in the show comes nowhere near
as close to the massive amount of damage that
Littlefinger has done to Westeros.
He is the mastermind of most major events
and he’s the one that’s paving the way
for this engrossing conflict.
I’m not going to go very in depth about
what makes Littlefinger so great since this
video is after all about fixing him and not
analyzing his greatness.
But to put simply he has a large impact, the
very nature of his character is very mysterious
and alluring, and the way in which he overcomes
his enemies and furthers his position is fueled
with high intelligence.
Making every scene he’s in very entertaining
and you’re constantly excited to see what
he’s up to.
Now in the later seasons, all of these aspects
about Littlefinger are severely downgraded.
Myself and other channels have been pretty
vocal about Littlefinger’s handling in the
later seasons, but I feel like I’ve seen
a common sentiment that Littlefinger was only
ruined in his final season.
Which I completely disagree with.
Or some people have even argued that his ending
was actually fine.
So for this section of the video we are going
to identify where everything went wrong with
Littlefinger and how he was downgraded so
much so I can then propose fixes to these
problems.
Funnily enough, the most pressing issue isn’t
actually Littlefinger’s death, but the exact
moment in which he betrays Sansa by handing
her over to the Boltons.
There’s a lot to dive into here and first
let’s try to understand Littlefinger’s
plan for season 5 because it’s very confounding.
So Littlefinger in an attempt to ally himself
with the Bolton’s gives Sansa over to them,
and he does this because he’s betting that
Stannis will win and liberate Winterfell.
His reasoning for giving Sansa over is that
since she’ll be at Winterfell already, Stannis
will then make her warden of the north.
However, that immediately doesn’t make sense
and is an extremely convoluted way to become
warden of the north.
Instead, he could simply ally the Vale with
Stannis and in exchange for helping, Sansa
becomes Warden of the North.
However, this isn’t actually Littlefinger’s
plan because he then gets summoned to talk
to Cersei and hatches an alternate plot with
her.
There he pitches a plan where he wants Cersei
to send an army of Lannisters to attack Stannis’
army after they win while they’re recovering.
She says no for obvious reasons, and Littlefinger
also proposes himself to attack with the Vale,
and in return, he wants to become Warden of
the North.
Although Cersei then says that she wants Sansa’s
head so I guess that immediately invalidates
this entire pitch because I assume Littlefinger
is lying when he says yes.
Given that he’s in love with Sansa, or maybe
he’s lying about that, I don’t even know
anymore.
I’d make the case that he does love Sansa,
and that kind of aspect about his character
is truly his constant.
But after this point, Littlefinger literally
disappears from the remainder of season 5.
This scene happens during episode 6 by the
way.
So Littlefinger is MIA for a long time and
I presume that he had no intentions of sending
the Vale to Winterfell since that would be
a major commitment, and he’d have to be
nearby to actually attack Stannis after he
won.
Along with him probably alienating the entirety
of the North by doing that.
So yeah, there’s a lot to unpack here from
how devoid of logic and unnecessarily complicated
this entire plan is.
Addressing the scene with Cersei first, I
assume Littlefinger was shooting for a hail
mary scenario in which the Lannisters would
take out the victor and establish him as Warden
of the North or something.
However, that would compromise Sansa, so that
wouldn’t make any sense.
This now makes me think that this entire scene
was just Littlefinger lying to Cersei to appease
her and if that was the case then that was
unnecessary.
Cersei is eventually going to figure out that
Littlefinger is working against her, so he
may as well just ignore Cersei and accept
her as an enemy.
Why bother going all the way down to Kingslanding
from Winterfell just to lie to her and gain
practically nothing?
On top of the fact that Littlefinger publicly
gave Sansa to the Boltons at Winterfell so
there is a risk in him going to Kingslanding
because of a possibility that Cersei was informed
about that.
Like she coincidentally summons him right
after he shows up in Winterfell with Sansa.
Hmmmm I wonder what she would want to talk
about.
So this entire scene with Cersei feels pointless,
especially since this set-up leads absolutely
nowhere.
Along with it making Littlefinger's plan very
confusing.
Now let's go back to Littlefinger giving Sansa
to the Boltons and assume that his initial
plan was betting on Stannis to win and to
establish Sansa as Warden of the North.
Like before, there’s a much better plan
available that achieves this same goal in
allying with Stannis.
Which doesn’t alienate Sansa.
That just seems like the most logical approach
to the situation.
Instead, Littlefinger throws away that which
he loves the most to THE BOLTONS.
In season 6, Littlefinger claims that he didn’t
know that Ramsay would be that unhinged and
goes the route of ignorance.
Like he’s not lying and genuinely didn’t
know anything about Ramsay.
However, Littlefinger as a character prides
himself on being extremely well informed and
would never act on a plan if there was a variable
that was a major question mark to him.
As an example, Littlefinger flat out kills
Dontas Hollard because he didn’t trust him
to keep his mouth shut.
Since his future allegiance was a question
mark, he decided that killing him would be
a permanent solution to that problem.
So giving Sansa away to an unknown figure,
whose the son of a ruthless father who massacred
her entire family is absolutely wild.
I feel like it would be safe to assume that
Ramsey would at least be somewhat like his
father and if not even crazier.
Although, it does seem like Roose Bolton is
mostly well mannered, but my point still stands.
In the world of
Game of Thrones with so many crazy lords,
it’s inherently a huge gamble to give Sansa
away to a random lord within a house that
is notorious for flaying people I might add.
That’s by far the most ridiculous thing
that Littlefinger does that immediately compromises
his character.
Littlefinger’s extremely convoluted and
nonsensical plan for this season is like trying
to navigate a complex web of hardened cum.
It feels like it was made by someone who doesn’t
understand the character at all because it
reeks of stupidity.
It’s very clear that David and Dan were
trying to imitate what Littlefinger would
act like given that they ran out of source
material for him.
From here, we have season 6 which essentially
downgrades Littlefinger’s presence in the
show.
It mostly feels like David and Dan gave up
doing anything with the character and pretty
much relegated him to trying to appease Sansa
for all of season 6.
Because rightfully so, his actions in season
5 were baffling.
And not in a way that you could understand
the fault, but in a contrived way in which
David and Dan bent the character into a direction
that made him very dumb.
This leads to season 7 where yet again, Littlefinger
has a completely batshit insane plan of trying
to get Sansa to kill Arya.
Now, Littlefinger is a character that naturally
has to take great risks to further his position.
Like orchestrating the entire conflict in
season 1 and conspiring to kill Joffrey.
However, the difference between those two
examples and his season 7 plot is that they
are much more calculated and safe.
He only conspires with people he trusts to
stay quiet and his plans are normally air
tight.
In season 7, he’s basically trying to convince
Sansa that Arya wants to kill her and become
Lady of Winterfell.
Which this is insane for a couple reasons.
Firstly and most importantly, Arya notoriously
did not want to be a lady and she wanted to
be a warrior.
This was very out in the open and Sansa even
hated her for that and wished Arya would be
more like a lady.
Since Arya’s more rambunctious personality
would oftentimes compromise Sansa’s happiness.
I started reading the books recently and they
go much more in depth about this while the
show partially shows this.
Sansa should immediately understand Arya’s
core wants in life and realize that Littlefinger’s
claim that she wants to be Lady of Winterfell
is bullshit.
I know people can change through life, but
Arya is still very much a warrior and if Sansa
was really suspicious of this she could simply
talk to her sister and try to determine what
her goals are.
Instead of taking Littlefinger’s advice,
someone she knows she can’t trust.
Another issue that doesn’t directly involve
Littlefinger as a character, is the contrivance
of this conflict.
David and Dan essentially bend Arya’s character
into being unrealistically cold and crazy
towards her sister when that shouldn’t be
the case.
Like Arya gets really mad at Sansa for writing
a letter to Rob to bend the knee to Joffrey,
but she was literally held prisoner and was
forced to do that.
Even Robb and his council immediately identified
the letter as being bullshit and for some
reason Arya goes crazy about this.
As if Sansa betrayed her house and this piece
of information will destroy everything when
it shouldn’t.
She even goes as far to act like she’s about
to kill her sister.
I feel like this is just an obvious example
of David and Dan exaggerating the amount of
anger Arya would feel here to create a false
sense of conflict.
Not even mentioning the fact that Sansa could
literally go to Bran for counsel about this
since he told her he knows everything.
Or Bran being the one to go to his sisters
and telling them about Littlefinger’s conspiracies
that he literally confirms to Littlefinger’s
face.
The fact that Littlefinger just brushes off
the notion that Bran knows about his secret
conversation with Varys is hilarious.
Bran is clearly indicating to Littlefinger
that he knows what he’s done in the past,
but Littlefinger for whatever reason, is completely
unphased by this and carries on with his ridiculous
plan.
These are the reasons why Littlefinger was
ruined and people generally focus solely on
his death scene as being dumb, but in reality,
it’s everything that leads up to this point.
Littlefinger’s terrible and ruined fate
was fully sealed by this point and his death
essentially evokes no emotion from how ruined
he was.
From here, I’m going to go into two parts
in trying to fix his character.
The first one being fixing everything within
seasons 5 through 7.
And then the second part will be pitching
an alternative path for the character that
would make more sense and would better suit
him.
So tackling the season 5 debacle of giving
Sansa away to the Boltons, I think the most
simple change would be to be more faithful
to the books.
In the books, there’s a character that is
friends with Sansa named Jeyne Poole that
the Lannisters send claiming she’s Arya
Stark.
In the show, Littlefinger can do this and
they could simply say he had her stashed away
in his whorehouse and has been working there.
Most of the people currently occupying Winterfell
don’t know what Arya looks like so it’s
actually a good plan.
And even if Jeyne is questioned about anything,
she would know the answers given her close
relationship with Sansa.
The only people that would know her true identity
would maybe be some Stark loyalists and Theon
Greyjoy.
Which I think this would make an interesting
dynamic in Theon trying to keep the identity
of Jeyne Poole a secret.
Essentially adding a more complex layer to
Theon in having to hide information from Ramsay.
Or maybe he even has to kill people who suspect
her identity is fake to protect her.
I admittedly haven’t gotten to this point
yet in the books, but it already makes significantly
more sense than what David and Dan chose to
do.
And I feel like the main reason why David
and Dan chose to put Sansa Stark in her place
is because they thought it would make this
subplot more dramatic.
Which I would disagree because we still have
Theon as a point of view character within
Winterfell and like the show, this could be
the event that causes Theon to defect and
save Jeyne from Ramsay’s torture.
There’s a much more complex plot with Mance
Rayder going to Winterfell to save Jeyne in
the books, but we physically wouldn’t be
able to do that since Mance is dead in the
show.
And I don’t think it would be necessary
and Theon could come up with a smart plan
to get Jeyne out.
Overall, this would be more logical from Littlefinger's
perspective because he both gets to keep Sansa
to himself and loyal to him, while also making
an ally with the boltons.
That and his plan of going to Cersei and getting
her to attack whoever the victor is wouldn’t
compromise Sansa because it would be Jeyne
instead.
Assuming he still wanted to do that.
This seems like such a low hanging fruit of
a fix that it just makes me think that David
and Dan didn’t really care about overall
logic and only wanted to raise the drama by
turning Jeyne into Sansa.
They severely misunderstood Littlefinger as
a character because even George RR.
Martin said that Littlefinger would never
betray Sansa.
And the sad thing is, if it wasn’t for Bran,
Sansa probably would have been manipulated
into killing Arya like a dumbass.
Which just seems so crazy to me that she still
listens to Littlefinger in season 7.
So that would be an easy fix to the biggest
problem in season 5 and I would also propose
a change in which the conflict within the
Eyrie, where the lords don’t trust Littlefinger,
to not be resolved so quickly.
I think it would be more interesting to have
at least one or two lords in the Vale to not
trust Sansa’s testimony.
Or maybe there’s a small hole in Sansa’s
testimony that one of the Lord notices and
investigates further.
Because currently in the Vale, there’s no
conflict for Littlefinger to overcome after
this trial.
Instead, I feel like it would be a more engaging
narrative if Littlefinger had to covertly
deal with one of these lords and kill them.
Essentially utilizing his primary way of overcoming
conflict of scheming and conspiracy.
This could pad out some time within season
5 and 6 because besides the Winterfell plot,
Littlefinger has nothing to do.
He literally vanishes from the narrative.
Littlefinger is clearly making enemies in
the Vale like him flat out threatening to
kill Lord Royce.
You could easily develop a plot thread from
there in which Lord Royce tries to exact revenge
on Petyr through his own plan.
But maybe Petyr makes short work of Lord Royce
because he’s inexperienced at playing dirty
and coming up with a plot to get Littlefinger
killed.
Instead, Royce kind of just rolls over and
easily submits to Littlefinger when I feel
like this type of character would try to rebel
out of pure spite for Littlefinger’s dirtiness
and dishonorable nature.
This again would give Littlefinger something
to do in season 6 because now that he wouldn’t
have alienated Sansa, there’ll have to be
new material for the character.
And I’m not sure if the books really cover
this far for him so this would essentially
be going into unknown territory for his character
that wouldn’t be derived from source material.
Because I obviously wouldn’t even try to
fix his season 7 plot and would rather that
be removed entirely.
This is essentially going into the second
part of fixing his character in proposing
a different direction and resolution for Littlefinger.
I’d argue that Littlefinger is the most
important villain in the entire show because
he’s the mastermind of everything.
So having him still be relevant in a major
way I think would be important for his character
and would be faithful to him.
Instead of utterly downgrading him to being
a Sansa simp and kissing her toes all the
time.
I think a longer term goal for Littlefinger
that reshapes the show would be more interesting.
While also being more in character for him.
For this pitch, since I want Littlefinger
to make a great impact like the earlier seasons,
that means I need to alter the final seasons
of the show.
So for season 7 I’m going to solely focus
the narrative on Dany’s war with Cersei
and then season 8 primarily dealing with the
Night King and the mad queen arc.
Or there could even be a season 9 where we
split the Night King and the mad queen arc,
but it doesn’t need to be that detailed.
My pitch would be after dealing with Lord
Royce and making sure his grasp on the Vale
is fully secured, Littlefinger starts conspiring
against Cersei.
In the hopes that by betraying her, Dany will
honor his loyalty by granting him more power
and wealth.
Some of the details here could be Littlefinger
killing characters in Kingslanding like maybe
Qyburn to destabilize the kingdom.
That could be a factor as to why the scorpions
were so incompetent in season 8.
Qyburn could have possibly been working on
designs and Littlefinger kills him during
the process, and Cersei half haphazardly implements
them even though they weren’t finished.
That’s just an example of something Littlefinger
could do that simultaneously solves some problems
in season 8.
One of the other ones being Qyburn’s awkward
and strangely funny death scene.
Or you could also save Kevan Lannister’s
character from being killed in the great sept
explosion and have Littlefinger kill him in
an attempt to weaken the Lannister army.
Because when you think of the sept explosion
you probably forgot that Kevan was even there
from how many other character deaths overshadowed
his.
So there’s a lot of opportunities for Littlefinger
to cause chaos behind the scenes and in the
process he could be offering up intel to Cersei
to make her not suspect him as being a spy.
After Cersei inevitably loses to Daenerys,
this leaves both the Mad Queen arc and the
Night King conflict.
Both of which I’d still have Littlefinger
playing a major part.
So this depends on what should come first
narratively because I feel like the Night
King conflict should be the final conflict,
but narratively it feels more natural for
it to happen before the mad queen arc.
So I’ll do a similar structure of season
8’s plot, but obviously different.
I won’t go into that much detail and will
only focus on what Littlefinger does.
After Cersei's defeat and Littlefinger once
again is awarded for his scheming, I would
expect Jon Snow or most likely Varys to convince
Dany to exile Littlefinger from Kingslanding
due to his history of being a snake.
He is not to be trusted.
Naturally this would upset Littlefinger and
this may be a major departure from where the
show went, but I think it would be really
interesting if Littlefinger got control of
the Horn of Winter.
Given that the show actually shows it in season
2 when the Nights Watch was at the Fist of
the First Men.
If you don’t know what the Horn of Winter
is, it’s rumored that the Horn, if blown,
will be able to bring down the wall.
It technically doesn’t come back up again
in the show, but maybe Littlefinger hears
rumors about it being brought to Castle Black
and he hatches a plan to steal it.
The way in which he hears about it could possibly
be through him eavesdropping on a conversation
with Tormund and Jon where they discuss the
Horn.
The wildlings apparently know about it through
reputation.
It would make sense that finding the Horn
would be a major goal for Jon so that no one
has the power of destroying the wall and unleashing
the Night King.
So this would essentially enact a race between
these two parties in trying to get to the
horn first.
In stealing the Horn of Winter, Littlefinger
would probably replace it with a fake and
at the end of an episode he’ll blow the
horn.
A cool moment could be Jon getting to the
Horn and then Tormund says that it’s a fake,
cutting to Littlefinger bringing down the
wall.
Thus unleashing chaos into the realm.
This would essentially act as Littlefinger
getting revenge on the lords in Kingslanding
and he will probably try to profit in some
way from the misery caused by the Night King.
I think this thematically stays true to Littlefinger’s
character because he wants to cripple the
realm and benefit off of its misery.
Which is what he did in the earlier seasons
and it would make sense for this to remain
being the case.
Along with the fact that Littlefinger would
probably be the only one to actually want
this chaos to unfold.
I think in the books Euron is also a possibility,
but the tame and destroyed rendition of him
would not make sense for that to happen in
the show.
So by making it to where Littlefinger brings
down the wall, this would also solve the major
issue in season 7 where Tyrion comes up with
the atrocious plan of kidnapping a wight.
That entire plot was extremely contrived because
even if Cersei believed them she still probably
wouldn’t help them.
Which is what happens and this plot only exists
to deliver a dragon to the Night King.
However, with my pitch, I think it would be
much better to make it a character motivated
decision that doesn’t compromise the intellect
of a bunch of characters.
From this point in the story, I think the
most logical path for Littlefinger would be
to retreat to the Vale and ride out the storm.
To not fully upset the lords, he might allow
some of his troops to help out in the overall
fight, but I’d find it hard to imagine that
he’ll help out completely.
Or maybe he’ll try to lie about his infantry
numbers.
After the heroes inevitably defeat the Night
King, this will now lead us to the Mad Queen
arc.
Now for this, I think a much cooler development
would be for Sansa to still doubt Dany and
overall dislike her, but to build up that
distrust over the seasons instead of it happening
instantly.
Then because of this, Sansa goes to Littlefinger
to conspire with her in taking down Daenerys.
In a way, Sansa and Littlefinger help orchestrate
the Mad Queen arc into existence by doing
different things like assassinating her closest
friends.
Maybe they could even convince Arya into doing
this and actually utilize her faceless assassin
skills.
I know Arya in the show also kind of has her
suspicions towards Dany.
So whoever survives on Dany’s side like
Missendei or something, could make for an
easy target.
A great scene could be Arya wearing Greyworms
face and uses it to kill Missendei.
Which would be taking out two characters with
one stone.
Then another example to drive Dany mad could
be planting evidence and making it seem as
if her closest advisors are actually betraying
her.
Like maybe forging a letter in Varys’ name
that tells the lords of Westeros that Jon
is a Targaryen.
There’s a lot of different things you can
do that play into the scheming aspect of the
show that can undermine and drive Dany crazy.
And from all of this, she begins her descent
into madness and overall paranoia.
She can’t trust her closest advisors anymore,
her friends that counseled mercy have been
assassinated, and Jon is slowly but surely
distancing himself from her.
From here, the same events can play out in
the show where Jon eventually kills Dany and
this means that Littlefinger makes it to the
end of the show.
However, Sansa knows the true evil nature
of Littlefinger and I think a suitable ending
would be for her to betray and kill Littlefinger.
Similar to the ending of season 7, but done
much better in my opinion.
Maybe a stipulation in Littlefinger helping
Sansa to drive Danearys crazy is that he wants
to marry her.
Which she obviously doesn’t want so she
betrays him.
Essentially ending her arc of becoming better
at playing the Game of Thrones and using what
Littlefinger taught her against him.
I think it would be nice if she comes to this
conclusion by herself and wasn’t necessarily
aided by Bran.
Bran could come to Sansa with the information
that he brought down the wall, but it makes
for building a stronger and more independent
character if she wasn’t given this information
on a golden plate.
And I know Bran is kind of a wildcard character
that with his very existence can curbstomp
Littlefinger out of the show, but I really
like the evil Bran theory in which he knew
what was going to happen but he let it happen
anyways.
Bran wanted to become the king and create
a prosperous realm, so he allowed all of these
terrible things to happen so he could get
there.
Which would be my reasoning for Bran not ratting
out Littlefinger right away.
He knew Littlefinger would serve his common
interest, so he allowed him to live.
Unlike the show where Bran steps in because
Littlefinger was about to manipulate Sansa
into killing Arya.
Littlefinger’s death won’t be a major
blunder made on his part that was just insanely
dumb, but a betrayal from someone he never
expected.
Sansa uses the lust that Littlefinger has
towards her against him.
So yeah, this is a massive rework for Littlefinger’s
character that I think would be much more
satisfactory than what we got.
I know it requires altering the story a bit
and how it’s formatted, but realistically
if David and Dan still cared about Game of
Thrones, then they wouldn’t have rushed
it with two shortened seasons.
Like it’s wild to me that they did Cersei's
downfall, The Long Night, and the Mad Queen
Arc in 6 episodes.
That’s purely insane and with this change
to Littlefinger it made sense to fix other
things that David and Dan also broke.
Because it would be physically impossible
to give Littlefinger a great arc in the current
state of the show.
Sorry this video ballooned in size and hopefully
my pitch for the character was satisfactory.
I’d love to go more in depth about it, but
this video would become 40 minutes long probably.
Thank you for watching and my Letterboxd,
Patreon, and Discord link are in the description.
And if you made it to this point then you
may as well subscribe.